whether it's fox or MSNBC or CNN you
often can't tell the difference you're
flipping from one channel to another and
they're all Trump all the time it's
Trump land
I see the media as a huge kitchen table
that stretches across the globe that we
all sit around and debate and discuss
the most important issues of the day
war and peace life and death and
anything less than that is a disservice
to a Democratic Society it is critical
in an election year to hear how policies
affect people on the ground not to get
the pundits but to get the people
themselves they're bringing you the
pundits and this is true on all the
networks the pundits who know so little
about so much explaining the world to us
and getting it so wrong the media
manufacturers consent for war for
candidates and elections by bringing you
more for example of one person like
Donald Trump he is pumped into
everyone's home he can just stay in a
gold gilded mansion in New York or one
of them in Florida the rest of the
candidates trudge from one state to
another why does he get this unfiltered
pipeline into everyone's brain into your
eyes and to your consciousness it
matters the Tyndall Center did a report
in 2015 they looked at the whole year
they found Donald Trump got 23 times the
coverage of say Bernie Sanders they
found ABC World News Tonight did
something like 81 minutes on Donald
Trump and I think they gave Bernie
Sanders 20 seconds Bernie Sanders is
breaking every record it's the only
reason he's getting any coverage right
now I mean the maybe he is shaming the
media in March he raised something like
forty four million dollars Hillary
Clinton raised 29 and changed million
dollars forty four million dollars that
hasn't been done before you break every
record and there's a blip in the
corporate media radar screen it just
shows how astounding it would be if he
got anything near the coverage of the
other candidates
could you imagine where he would be
right now in this high-tech digital age
with high-definition television digital
radio all we get is static that veil of
distortion and lies and
misrepresentations and half-truths that
obscure reality when what we need the
media to give us is the dictionary
definition of static criticism
opposition unwanted interference we need
a media that covers power not covers for
power we need a media that is the Fourth
Estate not for the state and we need a
media that covers the movements that
create static and make history